you don't consider yourself a chess
player nowadays but you have been
putting amazing performance after
amazing performance in the last couple
of years how do you balance your
streaming career with professional chess
and over the board chess as well well I
mean first of all I still do play
professional chess so saying that I'm
not a not a professional I mean that's a
little bit far obviously I think at the
end of the day they're 24 hours in a day
and I think during covet in particular I
learned how to use that time find a way
to um just balance everything and it's
just been a lot of fun bouncing
streaming and playing chess so I'm
having a great time